[Music]
this is actually here though yesterday
mom did you remember no Charles well of
course I did how does your date with
James there's no strings attached if you
wait too long we shrivel up like some
imported apricot sitting on the shelf
and waitress hello hope I'm not
disturbing you too late for that this is
an eviction notice you living on land
worth millions they really don't want
you here it's a myth only they got to
know me know now so how am i different
to what you expect us you seem cool on
cleaner
we're gonna help me man I put away your
calls at the months now every time
someone threatens your pride you puff up
like an emotional porcupine never stops
does it old world wants me to change and
now you too you really want us there
you'd have to fight for it the way I
live might seem different to a lot of
people all I care about is my home in
that regard and no different to any of
you just stay right there what are you
gonna do strongly to death
you're up to something mama what could I
possibly be hiding
[Music]
okay this is my
[Music]
he's very special just completely
transformed the way I look at life
doesn't earn I can point it the other
way if you feel like you're being
watched
[Music]
you